[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم تزامنا مع اشتباكات
جديده وسط الخرطوم اجتماع لممثلين عن
الجيش السوداني ودعم سريع في مدينه جده
السعوديه ونطق باسم الجيش يقول للجزيره ان
الاجتماع سيناقش تمديد الهدنه ولن يبحث اي
اتفاق نهائي لوقف اطلاق النار بعد تهديده
بسحب قواته من باخموت مؤسس شركه فاجنر
يقول انه تلقى وعودا بالحصول على الاسلحه
والذخيره اللازمه لمواصله القتال الجيش
الاوكراني يؤكد تعرض مقاطعات جنوبيه لهجوم
صاروخي روسي واسع وروسيا تعلن احباط هجوم
بمسيرات على مطار سيفيرني العسكري شمال
شرقي موسكو قوات الاحتلال تشن حمله دهم في
جنين ونابلس وتهدم مدرسه قرب بيت لحم
السلطه الفلسطينيه تهدد بالانتهاكات
الاسرائيليه والفصائل تدعو مقاومه
الاحتلال في كل مدن الضفه الغربيه بعد
غيابها لاكثر من 11 عاما بيان للجامعه
العربيه يفيد بان وزراء الخارجيه العرب
تبنوا رسميا في اجتماعهم قرارا ينص على
عوده سوريا لشغل مقعدها في الجامعه
واستئناف مشاركه وفود الحكومه السوريه في
اجتماعاتها الى اللقاء